India may be the world's fastest growing
economy today but millions of indians
are not reaping the benefits yet despite
is booming economy most of India still
suffers from lagging education and
healthcare services as well as extreme
poverty level how can we ensure the
country soaring growth means of crew
parole do you have a solution we want to
know what you think how can India is
fast growing economy benefit the entire
country the best video reply to this
question will win a trip to join us at
the World Economic Forum's in the
economic summit this remember in getting
upload your video reply to youtube and
tell us now